[Music]
all right what would you guys do if for
a Klondike bar
what would you do some like why I don't
I don't think I've ever had a Klondike
bar all right have you never it's it
it's the best thing in the world it's a
cookie it's like an oatmeal cookie so no
raisins with the the ice cream dipped in
chocolate no one'll cook it on that is
amazing yeah and half of it is chocolate
it tastes like Grandma yeah I mean like
I'll still eat like at least 20 of our
favorite you only 40 I don't like my
preferred cookie like I like [ __ ] I like
chocolate chip snickerdoodle sugar
cookie
those are eat 40 of them oh the cinnamon
sugar cookie oatmeal
what's your favorite what's your
favorite cookie cinnamon sugar cookie
and then chocolate chip oatmeal
chocolate chip is my number one feels
good yeah just chocolate really gooey
soft chocolate chip cookie in the world
do quarantine has been terrible for my
diet
you've been baking a lot I haven't
gained weight but I definitely got
flabbier like you know like where it
used to be like I got buff muscle you I
have like a good yes the way you show
your favorite on extra day you have to
think if you don't like guys there's no
fat there is last
he's like Julie the skinniest person
here I know Casey I'm about to probably
are huh how much do you listen I've won
probably 150 right now so you're ripped
you know what 50 say really you guys are
150 but Nelson has abs how much you
weight yeah 157 all right now round 157
yeah I'm trying to put on weight right
now so I definitely don't have abs right
now were you surprised cuz I look buffer
then I'm my waiting you look more than
seven pounds you're getting thicker a
good thick dude you just take steroids
gonna get hello jack why they have a
magic Jack Joe Bob you [ __ ] know
because I think what steroids is gonna
do
is gonna make me sexier but then less
hornier ya know I mix your hornier oh
really because a lot of testosterone and
you've got true jamali addictive oh yeah
I heard it makes my blasted it makes you
maybe you're horny but you can't get and
I don't want to lose his hair okay
I got beautiful hair be secure wife have
some kids first so it doesn't [ __ ] up
the jewels down there then do it old man
I plan on doing that want to be like
Master Roshi hell yeah and you're gonna
do it when you're 70 well hopefully I
can pop up a kid sooner than that okay
so maybe when you're 70 you look 35 Oh
true oh yeah there we go yeah looks good
but yeah
back to the what-if question what if you
are with your significant other or I say
you're just by yourself all right okay
there's a two-way different scenario
yeah well how about this if you're with
your significant other you just finished
say having sex okay and if you're by
yourself
say you're but a sneaking you just
finished jerking off or masturbating
right okay okay
and that's narrow you're you're cloudy
in the head right and you're kind of
very relaxed great yeah uh-huh
and then you hear and you hear sounds -
no no break-in so it's in your house
feel like that's tighter than the
[ __ ] car keys running out the front
door I'm chasing after your car I'm
chasing not this [ __ ]
butt-ass naked clothes yeah I'm gonna
chase them out too high with the gun and
shoot him in the [ __ ] safe I hear ya
if I hear a threat or danger I'm in the
immediate predator mode
what are you thinking where's your mid
[ __ ] I mean I'm already impregnable
I'm already an alpha predator mode so
I'm probably if it's even worse if I'm
in training outside with his [ __ ]
dick hard come about seeing while he's
chasing after the dude and that's quite
visual he's like hey man you interrupt
my [ __ ] all this for Silverado is that
what's it like I chose the wrong person
look at your honor
he's [ __ ] key
you know watches are imagine you have to
do that like you have to save or like
you catch her ro but then Sue's you for
like great great just a crime they break
into your house and they be heard of
those cases where they broke their arm
trying to break into people's houses and
then they sue the out the home yeah
California and justice is that
teleporter justice yeah so in Australia
Queensland's Sunshine Coast that's where
they're at a newlywed couple we're doing
a sex they don't didn't they actually
say the word sex in here I've been there
trying to like be discreet but they were
butt-ass naked and they said that it had
the robber come five minutes earlier
they would have no I have known what to
do so I'm assuming they were in the much
more passionate passionate state yes
yeah
so what happened is they're just
chilling now they're butt-ass naked some
robber comes in takes their keys and
they go and they try to steal the car
while I'm on then they spent two minutes
ho hopping around their own room trying
to figure out they should put on clothes
or not there's no you guys are saying no
talk about cool if I hear that boom out
the door boom Wow I feel like holy [ __ ]
sorry Bart what the [ __ ] what are you
doing here I left my keys I think I
wouldn't like expect the worse right
away if I just heard noise out there at
first I would be like what's up in that
time I think they're trying to figure
out what's going on close yeah you kind
of freeze right you're like you hear
that did did you hear that
is there a sound that would be the worst
in that situation to me like I just
cried the cat yeah
it is have keys to the house I don't
know the eyes hurt like this and then
the door closed and they're like butcher
I thought they heard cat house that we
know yeah you have to live alone too
much too much thinking dude you guys are
too logical cuz like after sex I my mind
is mush and I'm Way too tired to do
anything like if my car was on fire I'd
just be like oh okay
oh it's like that's what get a new one I
guess you're like I'm trying to think I
just need to sleep
this hurts me to try to be awake right
now whatever you need you took the TV
take everything I'll go talk to a little
bit do I even freak myself out when I
come home I'm like what if someone's
just waiting for me in the house right
now alright so I opened up the [ __ ]
door like this and I kicked that [ __ ]
open and I run to the back to see if
there's anyone that runs out the front
door and then I [ __ ] get through the
back open it that way give him a [ __ ]
knife and I start clearing the rooms
every night yeah yeah do you do this
every single day no that's just when I
feel that there's someone in the house
nah nah but there was one time there was
one time
I felt a little scared because I ran
back home cuz I was on my run and in my
back door was open and I said right so I
have my fall ready I was like I better
stop listening to [ __ ] the scorpions
and then I started coming in and then
I'm like all right I got not when we're
ready to go
the first thing I'm gonna do grab my
[ __ ] kitchen knife and then I [ __ ]
make some noise went into the other room
[ __ ] came in and I just remembered I
forgot to close the door cuz I was on my
phone yeah and I put the knife back and
I [ __ ] locked it and I was like oh
good boss call sabotage yourself leave
your door wide [ __ ] open you leave
the house and you come back somebody
robbed me no but I've done this to
myself where I think I left the stove on
Oh
when in fact I did
and I've had to drive home a check I
might turn leftist I thought I left the
stove on right before our honeymoon yeah
and I was like oh [ __ ] I think I left
the stuff and I was not me after our
honey it was before our bachelor parties
in Vegas so it's for like we're gonna go
be gone for four days and I was like I
think I'll have a stove on and then she
was like no you couldn't have let the
stove on it's definitely you definitely
remember to turn it off I was like I
don't remember turning it off but I've
also not remembered turning it off
before and I did turn it off so yeah
come to the end of the four day vacation
and I came home and I was definitely
still alive the entire time was anything
in the pot yeah there was nothing on the
stove it was just open flame because I
film tasted Tuesday right before I then
you cleaned up everything clean all this
stuff in the sink and that left the
stove on but luckily because I was like
holy [ __ ] but the cast was writing the
whole time but luckily if it's burning
yeah it's worse when there's something
on it if it's not then that's all you
know it's hard to [ __ ] scrub off the
black [ __ ] out that's on Bernard sure
man I [ __ ] almost overheated a
[ __ ] oxtail stew you know and I
showed the pot online and everything a
week later my mom's like hey make sure
you don't burn the house down I'm like
I'm not a [ __ ] idiot what are you
talking about who do you talk to you're
talking to she goes I saw your Instagram
story
and I'm like you're right thank you for
the reminder mom does that leave you
more paranoid it's like check every toe
yeah well ready paranoia I already feel
like I forgot to do everything like I
always like I think if I do this and
Steve's usually like I think you
remembered to do it because I'm so
paranoid but then when I actually did
forget to do something I'm like hope
this is why I can't trust me I treat my
stove like my gun where it's like I'm
always aware of what's happening with
the stove so even if I'm only using one
burner when I'm done like it's like you
know you're done shooting you clearly
good okay clearly perfectly well but
you're always now let's go click click
click click click just like just to like
be extra carrots you have a routine
I'm always seeing about the next thing I
have to do like that's it that becomes
the next most important thing yeah so I
think that's why I get so absent-minded
and I've locked my keys in the house a
million times I've like I have to do it
a 10-step program when I leave my house
to make sure I didn't like leave
anything in there that I can't get back
in my house I've been losing my wallet a
lot or not losing I just leave it
because with quarantine my routine is
[ __ ] up your core routine
my poor routine yeah like and especially
now I don't drive every day mmm I just
go Wow and I got my keys and then I'm
like if I get pulled over right now I
got my [ __ ] wallet
yeah I'm to me yesterday I can't even
buy nothing thank God for Apple pay you
know oh yeah so we're not really ever
stranded have you ever been to a place
where you're just like do you take up a
lot I went to gas stations like because
I knew I needed to fill up and I was
like on e and that in there without
you're on ecstasy yeah so what do you do
dangerous of driving look for like
hoarders or [ __ ] in my car because I
would have made it back I sense a gas
I've had to put like saving five cents
before look like if you order to just
look at this it worked though I go home
one time I that haven't me but I didn't
have a low pay but I had my debit card
memorized and yeah and the expiration
and the CV the CVV code
yeah and they took it Wow yeah so much
you have to type in manually when I was
doing the whole marathon training thing
I got really really thirsty and I could
have sworn I bought my car to my little
running pouch and I looked I didn't have
my car I'm like ah that's my text did
you know making you just take a picture
of my credit cards that are in my wallet
and I went into a 7-eleven we manually
did no wait so you're running in the
marathon you took a break at 7-eleven oh
no during the Train like during the long
run Oh teen or 16 miles on my all [ __ ]
I'm so thirsty and then I didn't I
didn't bring my car cuz the marathon has
like there's water and like oranges and
whatever on the whole time yeah which I
paid for that marathon and I did it you
did it it was right during the right
before the lockdown like though
before yeah interesting but I couldn't
use that excuse I already booked tickets
to go to Europe that makes sense yeah so
this story ends with the couple running
out naked screaming at the guy who's
trying to steal their car and then the
guy had the audacity to go I think it
was they didn't think it was them that
owned it
no I don't know good there because in
the accessor we stopped and thought huh
what are we doing and then resumed
screaming and the guy who's trying I was
surprised he didn't attack this they
decided not to go with clothes
yes cuz I think they're just like is it
really is a panic mode or should we just
go you know yeah and they were just
trying to figure it out I would have
just told the wife to put the [ __ ]
clothes on and call the cops while I run
out there that makes way more sense I
mean people don't know what to do in a
state of panic I probably won't either
I call it dick drunk like if I'm so dick
drunk I can't think about anything I'm
just like we gotta go to bed right now
true days over
[Music]